welcome to eldon ring i can't believe we
finally made it to the launch
first things first let's beat the
tutorial boss
i mean i call it a tutorial boss but
this place isn't a tutorial you're not
going to learn much here i mean you're
going gonna learn how to die and that's
about it
this boss is tough
plus the reset for this area if you want
to beat this boss first try it just
takes ages so learning his moveset is a
hassle and you need to learn his moveset
so eat your boiled prawns
and get ready
so you're probably wondering what's the
reward for beating this boss is it worth
it
i want to say yes it is worth it
especially if you want a powerful weapon
and powerful shield for the early game
by watching this video i think i can
help you get them so every boss has a
tax you want to look out for that was
one of them it's very exploitable and so
is this
if you see that attack winding up then
you'll have plenty of time to mentally
prepare for the parry although the parry
window is pretty tight as you can see
there so if you try this you're going to
want to choose a class with a 100
physical block shield the vagabond and
the confessor both have one the vagabond
has a lot more health and better armor
than the confessor but the confessor has
a heel which means there's a little bit
of room for error but the best starting
class for this encounter anyway is
definitely the samurai i mean he comes
with a long bow and a ton of arrows and
a really good longbow weapon art that
just lets you destroy this boss from
range you don't even have to really
learn the intricacies of too many of his
attacks
uh
so who is this boss the grafted scion
the name alone is super poetic and it
tells us so much
so grafting is a horticultural procedure
whereby tissues of plants are joined so
they can continue their growth together
now a scion is a young shoot or a twig
of a plant that is specifically chosen
for this purpose so this boss might have
been chosen for the purpose of grafting
but a scion also has another double
meaning in that asian is a descendant of
a notable family and based on the
weapons this boss is wielding there's
definitely some nobility there
the description of his swords reads
after falling from grace the drakes of
the golden lineage sought power and
purpose in the past i wonder if the
process of grafting was a part of this
past and i assume they're resorting to
this depraved act to get their power
back
that was a good fight
man just the feeling of practicing and
overcoming difficulty is so rewarding
and it's absolutely there in elden ring
some bosses are easy but some you really
have to learn everything about them and
that means there's something here for
every type of player i think
these swords should appeal to every
player they only require 14 dexterity
and 10 strength the shield on the other
hand requires 24.
so where do we go now
well you walk forward here and a great
crow carries your way
or not
[Music]
so i'm skipping ahead here i've leveled
up my character a fair bit and i've
cleared pretty much all of the stuff
that was within the fog in the closed
network test
it's definitely time to move on from
that content
we're headed south
so the concept with this edited play
through is to have a really good 30 35
minute session with the game going
through a lot of really good story beats
and exciting gameplay encounters and
showing great things that you might have
missed and showing off tips
everything
so this route that i'm taking through
the world it's really heavily planned
out but it has to be executed perfectly
in my eyes and i've actually attempted
this run multiple times by reloading my
saves
i was pretty happy with how this one
went
however just because i plan this out
doesn't mean i don't run into trouble
the game is still hard i will still fail
yeah so that attack is very cool you can
only use it when you charge up your
attack fully while the swords are buffed
though
so these soldiers that we're fighting
they are soldiers of godric who resides
in stormville castle upon their tabard
is a lion crest and it's the same lion
crest that was upon the shield that we
got from killing the grafted scion
according to that shield the lion emblem
depicted is sirosh an aged counsellor
who guides the golden lineage but the
golden lineage is clearly in disrepair
and these soldiers are not in complete
control of this area
hello
is somebody there
might i bend your ear for a moment
please
my name is arena
i've escaped from castle mourn to the
south
the servants there have rebelled i
i can't be sure what it is
my eyesight's been weak since birth you
see but i swear i heard frightful
howling from all over this poor woman
was being escorted out of castlemorn
probably via this carriage that lies
destroyed in front of us my good father
secreted me out the castle but decided
himself to stay
he says it's his duty
as commander we're fighting our way
through the dejected remains of arena's
entourage right there their bodies are
being savaged by wild dogs and worse
i
i fear for father's life
the servants are full roth
filled with hatred for every one of us
they've since come for every one of the
companions i escaped with they haven't
spared a soul
i fear it's no different at castle
mourning
please
i implore you would you mind taking a
letter to my father at the castle
my soul wishes that he escaped
even if his honor should be the price
what's so amazing about that whole
sequence is just how well it tells the
story through the environment but also
how well it humanizes all of the enemies
we just faced that doesn't happen very
often in souls games but it adds so much
to the world you know those beastly
creatures were former servants of castle
mourn which we're heading to now
and those soldiers of godric those were
simple soldiers enlisted to defend a
noble on her escape out of the castle
the giant was pulling the ruined
carriage the dogs were feasting upon
their corpses there was a story there if
you're paying attention to it
right now i'm prepping for what is
probably the most difficult encounter in
this run
it's a boss fight that only shows up at
night against the knight cavalry one of
those riders that was featured in a
previous story cut scene where they were
talking about the rune of death being
stolen
i want that weapon
i want that weapon so bad it just suits
the sort of dark templar confessor
character that i'm going for
so we need every advantage we need kukri
we need to sneak up on him we need to
use fire weapons
and i'm gonna use a flail myself because
the flail does bleed damage and if i can
bleed him out then that will be really
good because bleed is a percentage and
that's usually better against encounters
that you're under leveled for
also the flail is just cool as hell
especially when it's imbued with fire
i think the best strategy while you're
mounted against this guy is to try to
stay behind him and it's worth
remembering that you can quickly change
directions while doing mounted combat by
doing a double jump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
out of crimson flasks not looking too
good so i try to pull out the cookery
because i forgot to equip them i
desperately want to bleed this guy or
kill his horse so i can even the odds
you'll be surprised how much damage you
can do when he's off the horse
wow
this is where you get your damage in but
i am aware i'm one hit away from death
and if i let this go too long he does a
mounting up attack that does quick aoe
damage
so i decide to keep my distance
[Music]
done
and the rewards from this boss are so
good
barricade shield which you'll remember
from some of my earlier playthroughs in
the network test and the night riders
flail
24 decks requirement that's why i have
like no health but i do decent damage
now at least
after i'm done applying the ashes of war
it's time to go to round table hold this
is a place that you'll unlock after
defeating margat as melaner invites you
there
forgive me
i've been
testing you
to see whether or not grace truly does
guide you
whether you were fit to face the
challenge that entails
it seems my worries were unfounded
torrent had your measure from the very
start
whereas i merely pretended
there is but one other thing i can do to
offer you guidance
i can take you to the round table hole
gathering place
of tarnished champions
guided
by grace
oh this is a rare occasion
i can't remember the last time a new
tarnish made their way to the round
table
very well
as your senior
i bid you welcome
it is safe here
you may let down your guard
allow me a word of advice
as your senior
you are a mere visitor to the round
table nothing more
a house guest
yet to earn their keep
remember your place
newcomer
nice to have this dialogue play as we go
deeper into the round table hold with
our stone sword keys the senior has more
to say later on
oh
are you aggrieved
at the notion you were about a visit and
here
then you would do well to remember the
first words of grace given to you
stand before the elden ring
and become the elden lord
if those words held any meaning to you
follow the guidance of grace
lay low the shard bearers
and claim for yourself
a great rune
do so
and the doors to the round tables in the
chamber will open
and you will receive the wisdom of the
two fingers
once the wisdom of the two fingers
becomes your own i'll impart to you a
proper welcome as a true member of the
round table
oh i see you've just arrived
welcome to the round table hold
i'm current a man of the cloth
i teach incantations
the strength granted us by the two
fingers
and explore the secrets of the golden
order so that one day
if a tarnished of the round table hold
should become elden lord
i might cancel them
ensuring order regains its proper form
writing rule over men
by the way
do you still see it
the guidance of grace
you do
wonderful news
most tarnished are blind to it these
days you are something of a rare breed
well
what do you say
care to learn an incantation of the two
fingers
that
is a work of heresy its incantations
bear no lineage from the earth tree
very well
i'll take it off your hands
darkness is a spell that we'll use a
little bit later on it's an incantation
of the two fingers servants who once
served as the assassins of the round
table hold may the golden order shine
through you
these assassins were themselves once
tarnished who had strayed from guidance
and they pursued their duty in the
darkness that is without grace
maybe this played a part in our exile
you're a new face
no matter
it's all the same
lay out your arms
let's get smithing
i see you've noticed the chains
nothing special
i'm a prisoner and these are my chains
i'm trapped by the hole
i'm dying smithing for you fools
i love the atmosphere in this place the
round table hold itself almost feels
like a character
by way of example the blacksmith just
claimed that the roundtable hold itself
chains him
greetings great champion called by grace
i am fear
circumstances have compelled my stay at
the round table hold
great champion
would you allow me to hold you
but briefly
perhaps you might share with me some of
your lifely vigor
and your stout-heartedness
doing so will grant me the warmth of a
champion
and you i am sure
will bear a buldekins blessing
so that's fear the deathbed companion
that was mentioned in the opening
cinematic she's one of the famous
tarnished and i wonder what's making her
stay at the round table hold one thing
to bear in mind is that i haven't played
that much of the game yet i don't have
the answers i've had access for a couple
of days and in that time i've made sure
to only really comb through the early
areas as much as i can as of the time of
recording eldon ring is about to release
in an hour but reviewers have had the
game for a while and
man the response is insane a lot of
metacritic sites are having it hailed as
one of the best games of all time if not
the best by a lot of their metrics from
the biggest details to the smallest
like that forest watchtower shooting a
demi human
they've just done such an amazing job at
crafting unique encounters to cram into
this world and
it might well be a masterpiece
i know i'm always pretty positive on
from software stuff but
it's just a privilege to be able to
talk about this and bring it to you all
i hope i can do it justice you know
that's the goal
one interesting encounter is with these
candlestick phantoms that
lead you to points of interest
i look at where this one's going and i
realize there's a
little ledge underneath me that i can
jump down to
this leads to the earth bore cave
i think the name is implying that
something has borrowed into this place
there's so much to explore i kind of
forgot we're supposed to be on a quest
to
reach irina's father
it's so easy to get distracted
gotta explore the cave though i mean
look at that chest over there
nice of those two rats behind me not to
join in
i like that they give you kukri here
it's a bit of a hint i think that the
next boss is a bit weak to bleed attacks
which is usually the case for most
beastly creatures bleed and fire that's
the way to go
um for some reason he doesn't aggro here
i take this chance to get my sleep
potions ready i didn't realize they need
fp to throw
sleep has been nerfed a lot since the
network test but it's still pretty good
against the bear although they do need
to stand in that cloud for it to take
effect
the bear's asleep now i decide to do a
charge di2 attack here because with a
lot of bosses you can do a charged r2
attack and still get the critical
afterwards
not with this boss though apparently
ah
all right
i'm ahead out
it's a bit of a bore
that cave
so again as of the recording of this
video it's now 2am here and eldon ring
has officially
launched
it's an awkward place to be in as a
creator because all i want to do is just
play through this game completely and
not think about content at all but at
the same time i have to think about the
content it's my job and it's something
that i enjoy i enjoy bringing this game
to you all through my videos and that is
part of the enjoyment i get out of a
game release you know it's not just
playing the game for me it's creating
content about it that said
i get this fear of missing out you know
what i mean like i've just been hearing
fellow reviewers talking and venting
about how amazing this game is and
i
am only in the early stages of the game
and a part of me just wants to catch up
and rush through it but i have to stop
myself thinking that way you know like
fear of missing out is an awful feeling
and i just want to take my time with
this game and
really really savor it and
i think that's something we should all
remember
like don't just rush to the end of this
game don't just rush through it they've
spent so long crafting experiences and
you should do your best to take your
time in a recent video we talked a lot
about what these enemies are doing
they're unleashing the flame of frenzy
from their eyes the flame of frenzy is
essentially like a sort of eldritch
truth
it's something they've seen that is
driving them mad and the crazy thing
about it is that it can affect rats as
well
they infest this church of america that
we're coming up on now
this is actually where you get the flame
of frenzy spell
okay i'll be honest i died on purpose
here
no i actually i had merch about that
animation so i kind of needed to work it
in somehow
this incredible piece of artwork
inspired by the flame of frenzy was
worked on by chun lo who does an amazing
job with all my teespring designs so if
you need a hoodie or a shirt or if you
just want to support what i'm doing on
the channel then check it out
finally in the distance is castle mourn
the place that arena wants us to visit
to find her father
a funny thing about mourn and arena
those two names are very heavily
featured in dark souls 3. arena was a
blind faith character in that and mourn
was her kareem companion
she was in training to become a fire
keeper and she was inseparable from him
funny that they reuse similar concepts
like that
interesting that there's a smoldering
giant here
you have to start piecing together all
of the allegiances of different enemies
in this game and
right now i'm starting to think those
giants are on the side of godric
they are fighting to defend castle mourn
and the warden of castlemorn was
appointed by godric
although castlemore has been lost or at
least it's in the process of being lost
as you'll see
you'll recall back at arena whose
carriage was destroyed by the
ex-servants of mourn castle
those creatures were so beastly and you
have to wonder if a transformation has
taken place
although considering the demi humans
maybe this is just a race of beings that
is abused or taken advantage of
and like the demi humans they're
probably tired of it
so this fight is going pretty poorly
when you do six rolls in a row like that
that's how you know
good thing i have my
get out of jail free card
darkness
that guard counter comes out fast on the
flail every weapon has a different guard
counter animation you want something
that comes out quickly
and you want something that does a sort
of horizontal sweep in my experience
god the flail and barricade shield are
just a deadly combo you take like no
damage while blocking you do a quick
guard counter to follow up and you get
the flail and the ash of war from the
same boss which is cool
that said i'm the kind of person who has
trouble sticking to one weapon this game
just throws so many incredible options
at you how are you supposed to stick to
just one
but i think i'm gonna make that a bit of
a staple of this series if it continues
i think i'm gonna make a different build
every time and just show off a different
way to play and where to get the key
items for different builds
[Music]
oh
man i was gonna have a sick role play
here where i like sneak through using
assassin's approach while they all fight
that arrow in my head's kind of ruining
the seriousness of this scene
oh it's
gone i love that the enemies are
fighting each other there's just so much
drama going on in this sequence of
exploring the castle
uh there's a face i've not seen before
i'm edgar warden of this castle as
ordained by lord godrick himself but you
can see how things have turned out
the menials have all rebelled
they gave me good service also i thought
but it seems it was all an act
foul creatures as it said and true
enough they're foul inside and out
i'm sorry to disappoint you
but whatever you come here to do i'm
afraid castlemorn
won't hold much longer of course this is
arena's father and you can give him her
letter i see
from arena thank you
i mean you're dead
but i can't leave yet
even if the castle should fall
as commander i must remain
to ensure the treasured sword of mourn
does not fall
into the wrong hands
the legendary sword of castle mourn is
the grafted blade greatsword this
storied sword is a revenger's weapon
i'll explain more when i find it but
it's important to note at this stage
that the story of castle mourn is one
that is mired in themes of vengeance and
revenge
these themes played a part in the
ancient past of castlemorn which we'll
talk about in a moment
but these themes of revenge are playing
out in the present as well against the
nobility
fascinating that that noble is more
afraid of being eaten
and the disgrace that that would cause
him
then he is of death itself
maybe death isn't as big of a thing in
the lands between or
maybe nobility and being noble
is really important
if you see irina do tell her
that her father will come for her
once he's fulfilled his duties
according to some law that is written
upon great swords that are outside
castle mourn long ago this place was
under siege and in this siege a lone
hero fought for his vengeance only to
fall at the hand of lord godfrey
again this reinforces the vengeance
theme that is all over that legendary
sword that we mentioned earlier
honestly i'm kind of going out of my way
to use the darkness spell and make it
seem useful but in reality
i'm a bit doubtful about this one
although maybe it's supposed to be used
offensively instead of defensively
because while enemies are blinded they
are very very easy to backstab
so in this upcoming boss i use my spirit
summons for the first time
and
i think it's my kind of informal rule
that i'll use spirit summons if i'm
having a lot of trouble with the boss or
maybe if it's like a main boss kind of
thing
in general though i've noticed spirit
summons can make some encounters
ridiculously easy
although some bosses are also absurdly
difficult
[Music]
this boss isn't that bad by the way
[Music]
[Music]
i should be doing guard counters here
i should probably also level vigor
in my next fight with this boss i decide
to use the boulderkins blessing which is
the blessing we got from fear the
deathbed companion these blessings are a
powerful buff that consumes fp and also
they use up some of your maximum health
while you have them in your inventory so
it's best to find an opportunity for
them as soon as possible you are
very warm
what you felt light up inside you was a
baldicon's blessing though it is but a
fleeting thing i am afraid come back to
me
should you require another i will take
you in my arms
as often as you need
this boulderkin's blessing increases
your poise which is admittedly not very
good against a boss that can one shot
you but
hey at least it gave me a little bit of
my health back
[Music]
so
so we recover this sword of vengeance
and return it to edgar
i'm in your debt
for keeping the sword from those foreign
creatures
i'm no longer bound by duty
once i've rescued arena i will spend my
remaining days with
her brina
how could this be
my daughter deserved better
the fault lies
with me
i chose duty over my daughter's safety
and
that is how faith is answered
i'll find them
the foul wretch is responsible for this
i'll hunt them down and exterminate
every last one of them
rest assured
arena
it will be done
and so the cycle of vengeance continues
thank you for watching this very long
video leave a like if you enjoyed it
consider getting the merch that i
mentioned earlier and i'm so excited
that everyone can play the game now and
have adventures that are just like this
one
you